foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
Orlando Brown Jr Super Bowl champ
offensive tackle for the Chiefs four Pro
bowls in five seasons in the NFL kind
enough to join us before the big day the
big parade what's the schedule today
Orlando
um right now I'm starting to start my
morning off with you uh we'll head up to
the stadium around 10 9 30 I think we
leave the stadium for around 10 30. I
think the parade starts sometime around
then
um yeah and I'm looking forward to it
teammate most likely to be drinking now
is who
the question
um man Creed Humphrey Creed Humphrey for
sure okay I would have thought Kelsey
yeah he's probably up there but pretty
Humphrey for sure
the uh alignment on one float
do you guys uh yes we are yeah we are
yep yeah I think every position group's
got their own situation so I'm pretty
sure we got our own little trolley or
whatever they call it double decker now
do you bring your own drink or is it
supplied for you
that's a good question too I know I do
know that Creed's got some Boulevard
beer for us which is super popular here
in Kansas City
um but yeah I'll probably have my own
bottle of something with me as well okay
I don't want you walking out like Tom
Brady did when they had uh that that
boat parade okay where where it looked
like he was seasick and he had he had
his tequila and he threw the trophy so
just be careful there patience
won't be anything crazy for me like that
um the Super Bowl party how would you uh
describe it
oh man super cool man it was super cool
like you know obviously it's a once in a
lifetime opportunity to even play in the
game let alone win it and uh man I mean
you just felt that energy honestly all
week and man it was so gratifying you
know to to get that to get that win
um gosh man it was it was truly special
all right take me into halftime what was
said at halftime
yeah at halftime man
um gosh it was just it was a clear
message you know hey we gotta go take
this and if we want to win this game to
beat this really good football team
we're gonna have to go take it and I
mean man I was communicated from the
moment we sat down in there
um through all of the leaders uh through
coach Reed to coach EB you know
understanding the circumstances man this
is a really good football team and the
margin of error in any game is super
slim and against a team in the Super
Bowl like that that we just played the
margin of error was even smaller and I
mean man I mean they they turned the
ball over once and still only lost by
three points okay wait a minute you're
missing you're you're not letting us in
on the biggest message that Andy Reid
said to you guys about Rihanna
[Laughter]
[Music]
just keep on walking I'm like yeah I
remember you said something like that if
you want to see reality reality just
keep on walking
is the best man we're guys trying to
sneak out to see her perform no they
worked okay but yeah that's just coach
green being coaching uh the offensive
line we had heard about the offensive
line obviously what happened against
Tampa Bay and then that was the big
question mark and here's the here's the
Eagles you know they got uh all of these
sacks second most in NFL history in a
season
yeah
um how did you guys take that going into
this Super Bowl as a group yeah man I
mean you know it showed up on film I
think there definitely were the top unit
this year as far as Russian and passer
top to bottom they did an amazing job
all year creating one-on-ones uh Hassan
Reddick had a great year uh rushing the
pastor as well and they got a really
good system great coverage schemes the
way that they mix things up uh their DC
did a really good job of all of that uh
we knew it was gonna have our hands full
um but man the the understanding in our
office in line room is we set a really
high standard uh individually and
collectively and man going into that
game
it was understood it was going to be on
us and you know something that I spoke
about to the guys on Saturday was you
know precious privilege you know we we
heard all the talk about the 85 Bears
and how similar this defensive front is
and all of those different things about
what they've got and all that but at the
end of the day man I think the tougher
team and a more physical team won what
did you say after the game no sacks zero
sacks
put it on the T-shirt put it on a
bleeping t-shirt I think is what you're
saying that's exactly what I said
why did Mahomes bring you to Disney
World the entire group the offensive
line
obviously Pat does so much for us man
that's probably the one thing
I'm gonna do I enjoyed keep spending
time with my family not having to wake
up at 6 a.m to catch a flight to L.A
yeah and I what's that feeling like when
you give up a sack and Mahomes is there
on the ground like do you say anything
yeah I mean you know like as an
offensive lineman is it's that's
obviously the worst thing that can
happen to us and um you know for for an
old lineman man to give up a sack period
it's always a super uncomfortable
feeling and uh man especially don't let
it be on third down or too many or in
the game I mean I can't tell you how bad
of a feeling that is but normally I just
I just kind of let them know you know I
mean or you know or he'll say something
to me like hey that's that's on me I was
drifting I was floated it was coverage
or he'll be like block your guy
we're talking Orlando Brown Jr Super
Bowl champ offensive tackle for the
Chiefs how bad was that field
yeah you know what it was uh it was
pretty bad I would say I honestly I
didn't slip any at all like maybe I had
one rep where I kind of slid sitting on
a bull rush but uh man it was it was
super soft it was it was it was kind of
like it was soft like a very soft
surface
um you know your cleat marks were clear
in the ground and all of that
um I mean man I don't I personally I
didn't have to wear my seven studs I
don't think it affected my game at all
but I know people on the other side of
the ball were seem to be affected How
many pairs of shoes different shoes did
you bring to the Super Bowl
I always bring three cleats
um I've honestly never had a cleat
malfunction but you know I'm real weird
about my uniform malfunctions so always
at least keep three of everything what
are you gonna do with your Super Bowl
uniform
uh man I've got it here I'm gonna hang
it up I've got I've got all my cleats
from each game in this playoff series
um I got my jersey my uniform you have
my helmet
um then I'm I'm gonna hang everything up
and get it all framed awesome explain
the Lane Johnson
move that he has off the ball his get
off yeah is that legal
yeah definitely definitely I feel like
it's legal um you know so often you hear
you know fans talk about or announcers
talk about uh offensive lineman fall
starting we want to fall start here we
want this I mean listen man you're going
against guys on the other side of the
ball especially when you're on silent
Cadence especially on silent Cadence
you're going against guys that are
trying to use the snap count against you
that run four sixes or below that are
great athletes that are super long
and the way that Lane Johnson plays he
likes to beat guys to the spot and his
style of play is basically manipulating
You by creating more space and allowing
you to think that oh you have the inside
oh you have the outside why don't more
guys do it because I mean Lane Johnson
is one of the most elite players that
ever played a position his fundamentals
his athleticism his length his arms his
punch I mean top to bottom I mean he's
one of the best to ever do it and it's
not necessarily anything that can be
mimicked you know what I mean it's not
necessarily in my opinion a coach
technique you know what I mean this is
this is a Lane Johnson Style of play
that's why very rarely do you see guys
of his with his ability and I mean you
could say that about all the top guys
you know what I mean Trent Williams
learned me tonsil Lane Johnson Tristan
works all four of those guys I mean all
their games are so different
help me understand the Eric B enemy
the offensive coordinator position does
he is he calling the plays like like
just I don't I'm trying to figure this
out Orlando that here we are again Eric
bienemy may have to leave to be an OC
someplace else to show that he can be an
offensive coordinator which yeah I think
that's his job title in Kansas City what
am I missing yeah man personally man
it's like it sucks because I got a lot
of respect for Coach EB and you know I I
I'm pretty sure he calls the place and
uh man you know and in Casey it is a
collective effort I feel like with uh as
far as maybe what gets installed but I
know him and Coach Reed somewhere in
there like the plays are being called
you know through EV on the headset and
uh man that's unfortunate you know that
so many of these opportunities have come
up over the years and he hasn't been
able to uh you know get a head coaching
job and you know it's come to the point
where oh it's Patrick Mahomes and he's
under coach Reed so we don't really know
what he's capable of and uh you know man
it's it's unfortunate you know the
business side of things for him but uh I
feel as though man if he were to go
somewhere else if he were to become a
head coach where to become an OC
somewhere else I mean he's going to have
a ton of success yeah hopefully he gets
an opportunity make sure you protect my
homes today too okay it's not just in
the game you gotta you know make sure
nothing happens to him I hear you I hear
you I'll try uh have a have a good time
and congratulations Orlando thanks for
joining us yeah thank you all so much
appreciate you having me on Orlando
Brown Jr Super Bowl champ offensive
tackle four-time Pro Bowl
offensive tackle in Five Seasons there